in Europe we are all challenged with an  aging population and we have a lack of  healthcare professionals  in Denmark it has been a national  priority for many years to involve  patients and see how the patients  wants to improve their patient Pathways  we invite the patient to to give their  input and say  is there a possibility to do something  better for ourselves and together with  the clinicians there is a co-creation of  important questions of course with all  the important health status questions  but also questions that patients might  find important the patient do not have  to come and spend the whole day visiting  the hospital but can sit quietly at home  and fill in the questionnaire and at the  same time it reduces the number of  outpatient visits and we are looking  very much forward to the  collaboration that we will have in the  European Union about going in depth  without we can use data also for the  future health of our population  [Music]